well Peter Goodman is the European
economics correspondent for the New York
Times pretty good to see you know Airbus
is calling this a win-win for everyone I
doubt that Boeing is gonna see it quite
that way although Boeing is definitely
not portraying it that way they're
portraying it as an end-run there
they're essentially saying look you got
two companies that are subsidized
heavily by their governments they're now
linking up which makes their complaint
in the Boeing view even stronger and
simply shifting some of the jobs to
Alabama where Airbus makes aircraft now
and doing final assembly they're there
they're the term of art here is
circumvention they say they're simply
circumventing the intention of these
tariffs is this a case of the biter bit
I mean Boeing have obviously pushed
Bombardier into this position by taking
them to the US Commerce Department and
you know having these tariffs slaps upon
them I mean this looks quite an elegant
way for to dodge that bullet by
Bombardier well it does look L again and
it might work Bombardier and Airbus have
both taken pains to say listen this deal
has been talked about for a couple of
years yes a happy circumstance is that
this would presumably get around the
tariffs in their view but that's not why
they're doing it now they have to say
that that also might be true that's one
of those things as an outsider it's hard
to know so is this gonna get off get
them off the hook is this gonna help the
CSeries avoid these tariffs that have
been imposed by the US Commerce
Department's well it certainly
complicates the situation I mean Boeing
brings this complain and they say these
airplanes are subsidized and therefore
they're being sold really cheaply so
cheaply Delta Airlines a major American
carrier places this big order for them
and the Commerce Department comes in
with these preliminary tariffs of 300
percent now certainly being able to say
these planes are no longer made in
Canada they're made in Alabama a state
that by the way overwhelmingly supported
the guy in charge president the United
States Donald Trump that certainly helps
their case but it's gonna come down to a
legal determination of what the real
country of origin is here now now air
Bombardier excuse me says that even
before this deal something like 50
percent of the components in these
planes
were made in the United States so their
view from the outset is it's quite
simplistic to simply call this airplane
a Canadian import any more than you can
call a Ford automobile that's made in
Mexico made with 40 50 60 percent parts
that are made in the US plus some stuff
from China and south and Korea that is
that a Mexican vehicle I mean the same
sort of question is gonna hit us here
but it's gonna involve an awful lot of
trade lawyers huddling up at the
Commerce Department in Washington
welcomes a win for the lawyers obviously
I mean quite ironic that Boeing went in
as aggressively as they did given that
they didn't even have a product to
compete with the CSeries
right that's that's a key element to
watch here I mean they were not bidding
on this particular deal from Delta and
the the greatest surmise we can come up
with on this is is their understanding
that the way the winds were blowing with
Trump in the White House is that this is
a Commerce Department that's friendly to
a complaint from a major American
employer a major American manufacturer
claiming that a foreign company in this
case a Canadian company is unfairly
subsidizing their goods and in fact
Trump is taken on Canada across the
board there are lumber cases that are at
issue there are mining issues between
these two countries dairy issues and and
the the theory here is that he took
office
threatening Mexico and of course they're
now renegotiating the North American
Free Trade Agreement and that continues
threatening China but China turns out
plays a key role in pressuring North
Korea to to relinquish its nuclear
aspirations and so suddenly there's some
soft peddling on China Canada pops up
again and again as the reliable punching
bag for the Trump administration as it
presses this you know America first
mantra on trade Goodman I'm afraid we're
gonna leave it there appreciate you
joining me thanks very much for having
kids